et
déjà quand je rentre dans le domaine
on a l'impression de passer dans un
autre monde pour rencontrer la sérénité
le calme revient peu d'esprit aussi un
peu malgré tout nos dimanches au corps
des religieux se sont quand même assez
ouverte sur le monde extérieur même s'il
s'agit de moniales donc de gens par
définition cloître et si vous voulez
cette abbaye un rayonnement
extraordinaire on pose très souvent
cette question oui alors que derrière
ces murs
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière un mur beige
répond y est et du boulot c'est tout
quoi
à
saint michel de kergonan à plouharnel
dans le morbihan
certaines monial il réside depuis plus
d'un demi siècle
aujourd'hui le monastère bénédictin est
habité par 34 femmes de 33 à 95 ans
elles vivent ici selon la règle de saint
benoît
celui par qui le monachisme devait
essaimé en occident les moniales
bénédictines assistent à cet office
quotidien entièrement chantée en latin
après les laudes le premier office du
matin c'est le moment de la lectio
divina chaque monial réfléchi seul dans
sa cellule
sur un thème de la foi qui lui est cher
c'est à partir de cette méditation que
la journée de travail prend tout son
sens
quand j'ai lu midi terminé quand je me
trouve après dans mon travail je me sers
de tout ce que j'ai appris pour aborder
les autres
peut-être si dieu me donne sa grâce est
honnête un peu plus douce avec ma soeur
qui à ce moment là que peut-être
m'énerver beaucoup en faisant trop de
bruit monzon chose j'ai pas du tout
envie là j'ai appris dans ma lexicaux
quelque chose une décantation une
purification
ça c'est là c'est ça c'est l'exercice
et c'est là que se fait la liaison entre
de travail matérielles et le travail
spirituel et que ce fait toute l'unité
du moine dans sa personnalité à lui
ici le travail se reçoit dans
l'obéissance
c'est la mère abbesse qui distribue les
charges à chacune plusieurs par monial
tous les trois ans soeur catherine
s'occupe de la ferme
aidé par soeur marietta mais elle est
également la celle et rier c'est-à-dire
l'économe du monastère la ferme située à
l'intérieur de l'enclos du vaste domaine
de 25 hectares est entièrement bio une
rareté dans le monachisme français la
terre c'est l'héritage qu'on en prenne à
ses petits enfants
ça ne va pas retient pas là non plus bon
on reçoit ce conte ce que les anciens
nous ont donné et il ya toute sagesse
qu'on a voulu oublier qu'on a transformé
ou qu on a piétiné et en fait ce qu'il
faut retrouver c'est cette sagesse avec
ce que la science peut nous donner
aujourd'hui c'est vous et la technologie
les soeurs de saint michel de cargos
n'en achète chaque année des veaux
qu'elles revendent quand elles sont sur
le point de vêler à des éleveurs bio de
la région depuis la fin de la guerre les
soeurs avaient une orientation
biologique au monastère donc si vous
voulez les travaux que nous avons faits
ne sont pas une innovation dans le
monastère c'était une tendance
thierry philip achète depuis cinq ans
les génisses des moniales c'est un peu
grâce à elle s'il s'est lui aussi mis au
bio
à plus long terme que ces milieux
agricoles conventionnel elles sont
conscients que deux demain il y aura
sûrement des bouleversements ces terres
qu'ils font qu' il faut la travailler
autrement
mais vous savez ça va s'ouvrir le dos
les produits du verger du potager
suffisent amplement à la consommation
des moniales
marcel grillon marche le jardinier du
monastère est le seul homme à travailler
à l'intérieur du domaine du fait que
nous sommes bio ça nous donne davantage
de travail tous les entretiens des haies
fruitières rien les traiter tout et
entretenir donc à la main devant un
gyrobroyeur bon une barre de coupe
et puis la débroussailleuse tous les
entretiens se font la main aucun
traitement et ce qui nous donne beaucoup
beaucoup de travail
tout le travail se fait ici dans le
silence ce qui permet ainsi la prière et
la contemplation l'ère des quatre
préceptes fondamentaux de saint benoît
la messe de 10h et le sommet de la
journée monastique
c'est soeur jacqueline la sacristine qui
la prépare tout doit être prêt pour
l'arrivée du prêtre et de ses vicaires
attiré par la beauté de la liturgie et
les chants grégoriens les fidèles
viennent nombreux les dimanches d'été
assister à la messe de 10h beaucoup se
rendre ensuite au magasin pour y acheter
des produits monastiques de sainte anne
de kergonan donc juste juste voisins
nous avons été fondé une petite année je
crois ou deux avant avant pour être
présent dès l'arrivée des moniales
justement pour pouvoir être être à leur
service entre autres pour pouvoir venir
célébrer la messe tous les jours et y
apporter ce ce soutien c'était de
spirituel des sacrements
si chacune des moniales à un certain
nombre de charges abstrait tout
participe aussi aux tâches ménagères
quotidiennes y compris les anciennes qui
le désirent
après l'office de sexe on se dirige en
procession vers le réfectoire pour le
déjeuner qui se prendra également en
silence
la tradition de l'église
m je crois que ce principe d une
histoire lorsque le sig est une histoire
un higoumène fit un jour une homélie sur
la création
l'homélie plutôt longue fini sur ses
paroles
chaque brin d'herbe est une homélie pour
ceux qui savent comprendre quelques
jours après un père passe à près de la
cellule de l'iguane et vic l'ancien
était en train de couper l'herbe qui
avait poussé tout autour je vois avec
plaisir à bâle que tu es en train de
raccourcir t homélie
l'été la récréation se terminent souvent
par une promenade dans le pack le
dimanche on vient aussi parfois chanté
une antienne au cimetière il a ce sont
mes derniers retombent à dernière sera
ici est encore toute une rangée de potes
de prévu là et après ça on irait dans le
champ de pommes de terre
quand on dit sera plus
avant nos frais énormément dans
l'émission par exemple je regardais en
1938 on a offert 16 chasuble pour le
démissionnaire mais laurent feuille
c'est minimum comme prévu on peut
certainement pas gagné bien sort de la
voiture et d'épées et de la broderie
je peux travailler en silence et qui me
permet de briller le penser à dieu
d'élaborer des choses
chose que je dois faire mais je ne
m'occupe absolument pas du rendement
d'ailleurs je ne sais absolument pas ce
que je gagne et j'allais dire j'ai la
chance de pouvoir dire ça ne m'intéresse
pas
nous gagnons notre vie honnêtement et ça
nous cherchons à le faire espère voir
décision utopique qu'une monia elle ne
travaille pas mais là c'est derrière ne
viendra pas la trouver en lisant ma
soeur il faut vous stressé parce qu'il
faut gagner plus c'est sévère de
questions dans un monastère y en a une
ou deux qui sont désignés pour le porter
à la place des autres
il ya la baisse d'abord quels soucis
matériels et spirituels et au monde et
puis elle dédie de sa salle arrière pour
tout ce qui est matériel
en gros les pensions des anciennes
représente une la moitié plus même de
nos revenus
donc oui ce samedi déjà quelque chose
les activités des soeurs représente en
gros donc y compris le
le magasin représente en gros 28%
tous les travaux qu'on peut faire on les
fait en fait c'est ce qu'on appelle nous
on rentre dans l'extraordinaire on le
fait grâce ou donc on peut recevoir ou
bien de personnes proches du monastère
ou bien de personnes inconnues qui nous
donne ou bien de monastères qui nous qui
nous aide sur katrina cri avec l'aide
d'un ingénieur agronome une gamme
complète d'engrais et de fertilisants
bio entre les premiers essais faits et
la première sortie je crois que cette
durée 18 ans 18 ans on a fait des essais
mais c'est aussi parce que j'ai toujours
des idées un petit peu original alors je
change toujours mes affaires et je
modifie parce que j'ai une autre idée et
donc qu'il fallait que j'arrive à
canaliser et à stabiliser mon affaire
depuis à peu près six ans je crois que
j'ai pas acheté une fois un insecticide
ni un fongicide à la base
ces produits sont constitués d'ortie de
presles et d'algues
je vais donc mélanger ça bien de brasser
je vais le recouvrir intégralement et le
laisser macérer pendant un certains
nombre de jours qui dépend en fait de la
température et quand je verrai que le
purin est prêt à utilisation je devrai à
ce moment là sans retard fabriquer faire
une fabrication de plantes abel et le
client du tirage
un nombre de litres selon la quantité de
produits que je me fabriquer en finale
vous avez une épice voyez en fait qui
est qui était le les lis du tank à lait
parce que dans un tank à lait que vous
avez toujours un mouvement mais dont on
a modifié un petit peu les orientations
afin que le liquide soit toujours
brasser doucement y ramener vers les
côtés pour avoir un produit très
homogène et sans aucune brutalité
c'est très important en fait oui ce qui
est important aujourd'hui c'est que on
peut utiliser des matières nobles et en
même temps si on a des machines qui nous
casse les molécules parce que les
marteaux sont trop puissants ou si on
monte en température trop élevée
concrets d oxydation et en fait on à la
sortie des produits qui sont détériorées
mais soeur catherine ne compte pas
s'arrêter en si bon chemin
il ya elle travaille actuellement à un
élixir buccale bio bien entendu
ce nombre est un peu l'âme qui qui
prêchent un dieu unique baba c'est déjà
ça c'est déjà quelque chose à un actif
très important où il ya toutes les
religions qui prêche une morale qui est
à peu près conforme à la morale
chrétienne
certains théologiens et des théologiens
tout à fait hors taxes comme le père de
l'asu jeunes pensent que ces médiations
pourrait même être d'ordre sion naturel
c'est à dire qu' il pourrait même y
avoir des grâces surnaturel qui passe
par d'autres même par d'autres religions
actuellement encore les hommes qui n'ont
pas reçu donc qui vivent dans d'autres
si d'autres religions qui n'ont pas reçu
effectivement la révélation chrétienne
se retrouver également
même dans le cas de même dans le cadre
éventuellement de la religion mais c'est
quand même délicat parce que mais
pourquoi qu'ils veulent qui le cherche
oui 2 561 s'ajuster à 10 ans sont des
gens qui vivent selon le verbe ex
préfère être réparé bon bah j'espère que
je devrais virgile quand même merci
virgile qui a annoncé virgin qui a
annoncé le beci aura du moins qu'ils
aient tous les bons coups les bons créé
tous les pères de l'église et tous les
chrétiens du moyen-âge pensait que
virgile avènement c'est le christ dans
les médiations des civils et il a écrit
quelque chose de ravissants là dessus
alors quand même c'est pas possible que
virile ne soit pas si sûr que géré il
est au ciel
en 1898 23 monial prennent possession de
la l'ouest de saint michel de carbonneau
en 1901
quand les lois laïques les oblige à
s'exiler en angleterre les murs de
l'église commence à peine à émerger du
sol lucie schmitt est la première mère
abbesse du monastère
heureusement elles ont pris la
précaution avant de partir de faire deux
places et un glacier de 6 mo sur tous
les murs parce que les murs de l'église
élevé jusqu'à la hauteur des vitraux les
architectes entier s'il n'y avait pas eu
ça on n'aurait pas pu re enfin continué
l'église en 1919
elle rentre en france et reprennent
possession du domaine entre 1943 et 1945
l'occupation du monastère par l'armée
allemande oblige les moniales à un
nouvel exil donc la percer derrière de
l'époque maire geneviève était resté ici
avec deux ou trois soeurs qui
s'échangeaient terrain pour cultiver
pour soigner les bêtes et ça lui
permettait ainsi de ravitailler la
communauté qui étaient installés dans un
vieux château un tranchant plus
redondants pliant en 1945 elle se
réinstalle définitivement
la ferme prend alors son essor mais ce
n'est qu'en 1967 qu'elles peuvent enfin
reprendre les travaux de l'église
abbatiale
il est entré au monastère lieu une
personne veuve qui n'avait pas d'enfant
et qui avait une assez belle fortune
naturellement j'allais fille elle s'est
révélée un usage moyen donc comme
l'avait fait miroiter ça fait rien on a
commencé la monastère c'est une famille
dont c'est comme dans le monde chaque
famille a sa caractéristique sa marque
un peu de famille où je pense que ça
m'est cher il ya une marge
certaines marques c'est une certaine
liberté v nous sommes devant devant la
mer au grand vent quelque chose de
permis d'un talent
oh
le bo a plus d'importance encore que
jamais et pour les monastères justement
les jeux on trouve le beau dans la
liturgie salle et évoque le sacré il dit
le bout et objective d'une certaine
façon mais il ya une certaine connivence
avec notre subjectivité donc et il est
moins écrasant pour l'homme contemporain
que le bien le vrai problème en faut
faire et floch
mais il faut y arriver petit à petit
parce que
le bon niveau tout dépend de l'homme et
puis nous mène bien d'où venons nous et
nous disait aussi finalement les gens
ont besoin de retrouver ces trois
questions fondamentales qui se nouent
d'où venons nous et où allons nous